washington is on high alert
nearly 5 000 national guard in place
this is the day some followers of the q
and on conspiracy theory believe donald
trump
will make a triumphant return to power
march the 4th was
until 1933 the official inauguration
date for presidents
the trump hotel appears to be eyeing a
big payday
it's raised prices to over 1 000
a night more than double what you pay
for any other night this month
we've been here before some americans
thought mr trump would eventually return
to the throne in january
that change would come it didn't of
course but that hasn't
extinguished hope some former believers
tell me
q anon is a doomsday cult where failed
prophecies
only serve to further inspire members
when a date doesn't work
they look to another at its heart
q anon is based on the bizarre unfounded
theory that donald trump
is waging a secret war against elite
satan worshiping paedophiles in
government
business in the media but it has many
offshoots i really did believe
that he was sort of this messiah figure
you know that was had our you know was
going to save the united states
melissa's faith in the group led her
here
a tirade about masks it went viral
watched 100 million times on social
media i'm not doing it
i'm not doing it no i'm not doing it we
don't we don't want any of this anymore
this is over
no no dude why why you let everybody
else do it
can everybody else do it i can't do it
because i'm a blonde white woman
she now says she was having a mental
breakdown and has spent
months apologizing and trying to rebuild
her life
it really was the worst day of my life
my husband filed for a divorce
you know i was a pariah in my community
i lost my job i
basically lost my business do you feel
like there
are quite a lot of people trying to
break away now that realize that q anon
is not something they should be involved
in
more and more people are digging in
their heels
and now you know because they've all
been swept off of social media sites and
and you know the internet they're kind
of going into hiding
and they they're potentially becoming
even more radicalized
fringe theories have made their way into
congress
but support groups like q and on
casualties on reddit
have also grown rapidly it is just full
of stories
every day of people talking about their
decades-long marriages falling apart
mothers committing suicide after joe
biden's inauguration
it's just it's a really sad place the
fbi has designated the group
as a domestic terror threat its survival
may depend on just how many people are
willing to suffer
endless disappointments cordelia lynch
sky news washington